what's the theory behind starting a
session with carpros second at Big Cavs
I have started with Cavs for more than
10 years now if you go ground up legs
wise your calvs are nice and warm and
then I do hamstrings next when I put
them first and then I doubled the amount
of volume and I did them in every
workout rather than two times a week
that's when my C started to really grow
I think that there's something
definitely underrated about starting a
session with a real low investment
movement like no one's ever going to say
no to another set of car phrases I don't
think many people have the same approach
to training Alex does not many people
begin their workout with 100 repetitions
on Cals and not many people do the exact
same routine every single session full
body